let me start by saying how much i
absolutely loved this movie
it is so good um i just i'm
i'm so impressed with what you guys
pulled off in the animators
um and that's all i have i'm done i'll
see you guys later all right
take it easy right um no but being being
serious when you were making this um
i'm you obviously knew what the script
was as during the development process
but seeing the finished film
with this animation um added to it was
so good
i'm just curious for each of you can you
share what was your favorite part
of watching the finished film the film
goes into like katy vision
sometimes when it really amplifies like
a way in which katie's feeling
where like something goes and like blows
up because it's the way she's feeling
inside and it kind of
it always reminded me of ally mcbeal uh
you guys remember that reference but
it just felt like so refreshing and it
is so much about
you know the way in which she she feels
in her own body and using her creativity
to sort of
uh heighten it and show the viewer what
she's feeling and like this
totally i i was saying earlier i don't
know the right vocabulary for how this
animation style is different
but it is whatever it is it's different
and it's like different
at every turn it's very surprising and
that was
yeah like that was the most exciting for
me beck and i were texting
like we both were watching it sort of at
the same time and sort of blown away by
it
yeah yeah i mean like in katie's world
it was kind of like oh that's
interesting that's unique
um and i like it was something i hadn't
seen before
and it was fun because you could see
your creativity and then it like even
when we when we go to the robots and
it's just like something about the
some of the robot action and the score
that
uh mark came up with which is incredible
it's like
oh the robots are here and the tone of
the movie just shifts so much
and it made me like like i'm not usually
scared by
animation but it like made me
uncomfortable because the other family
world is so much more
warmer so it's just like i don't know it
was really incredible to see that
difference and how it made me
as an audience member feel i remember
going to say like
i think when when what um abby's calling
katie vision happens this movie is so
much mike's
my granda's heart and like he is just he
is a true
artist he is a true animator he is this
is his
heart and his brain and his world just
erupting and come to life and it isn't
like anything we've ever seen because
this is someone who is genuinely um
just gifted and has such a clear
vision and sense of self and he really
is all of these characters he really is
this family and um there's so much of
him
in all of these characters so i've never
seen this movie before
and i was so um i was so excited i think
once i finally saw
the finished product to see it come to
life because i knew what he was capable
of
because i knew his passion for getting
his
heart and his vision out there and you
can see it it's truly
him and it is completely unique and
so inspiring like really really so
creative and then and then so much more
than i expected
i think i remembered the question which
is why i think i came around to the
yeah i'm just gonna say thank you i'm
already out of time
um good luck with the rest of your speed
dating and thank you so much